لما يقولوا: يا خدامة! يا خدامة أنتِ تعالي
يوميًا لقيمات، يوميًا لازم لقيمات
لما إحنا خلاص نفطر
ونشرب مويه وكذا الحمد لله
تحس أن الدنيا حلوة
اسمي ميمونة
من إندونيسيا
عمري 42
لمّا جيت السعودية
يمكن عمري 19
عمري 19 سنة
أول شيء في المدينة
بعدها رحت دبي
بعدها جيت الرياض
من 6 سنوات
يعني هذا كله 16 سنة
أنا ما درست في الكلية
بس الثانوية، الحمد لله
في بلادنا إذا ما درست باجتهاد
صعب مرّة تلاقي وظيفة
هل تتضايقين إذا ناداك أحد «شغالة»؟
أحيانًا
لمّا أحد يقول
«يا خدامة!»
«يا خدامة أنتِ تعالي»
قلبي يألمني
قلبي يألمني لمّا يقولون عني كذا
إحنا كلنا بشر
صح ولّا لا؟
بشر، وبني آدم
أحيانًا لما يقولون كذا قلبي يألمني
بس مو مشكلة
إحنا عندنا صبر
بس أتمنى ما يصير فيه أحد يقول هالشيء
عاملة أفضل
من إنهم يقولون
«يا خدامة»
بهالطريقة
طيب و«شغالة»؟
صح هذه بعد
أصير أقول
أنا ما أبغى هذه الوظيفة
بس إيش أسوي؟
يمكن هذا نصيبي
كيف تتعاملين مع كبار السن والأطفال؟
لازم الصبر مرّة
مرّة صبر
كبار السن.. هم الكبار بالعمر صح؟
أحيانًا يصارخون
أحيانًا أسوي شيء
يقول لك ما سويته
أعطيني مويه
أعطيته المويه
أعطيته الأكل وكل شيء
يرفض، أنتِ لسا ما أعطيتيني
لازم مرّة الصبر
حتى لو إحنا مثلًا نشتغل
عند الأم الكبيرة
والأب الكبير
تمام؟
كأنهم والدينا
والأطفال بعد
هنا فيه أطفال، وهنا ما شاء الله أطفال
أنا أشتغل داخل البيت وأعرف
أنا في إندونيسيا
يمكن أنتبه على خمسة أطفال
ماهي مشكلة
هنا واحد بس ما شاء الله
مرّة شقي
صح أنه لطيف ما شاء الله
بس مرّة شقي
هل سبق وتعرضتي لمواقف محرجة؟
أحيانًا
مثلًا الكأسات
دائمًا وإحنا نغسل المواعين
يمكن ينكسر أي شيء
مثل كوب مثل صحن
بس أنا لازم أتكلم معاهم بصراحة
لو أنا كسرت شيء
لو أنا خربت شيء
أقولهم
«مدام أنا آسف أنا خربت هذا»
«ماهي مشكلة»
بس المكنسة الكهربائية
كيف خربت؟
المكنسة كانت تشتغل
لما حطيتها في الكهرباء
ما اشتغلت
أنا مباشرةً تكلمت معاهم بصراحة
قلت
«مدام المكنسة الكهربائية ما تشتغل»
قالت: «ليش؟»
«كانت تشتغل أمس»
«لا. لما وصّلتها بالكهرباء ما اشتغلت»
«هذه غالية ولازم فلوس»
بعدين
«خلاص الحمد لله»
«بنشتري وحدة ثانية»
كيف جدولك في رمضان؟
في الصبّاح أصلي
وبعدها أنام
إلى 12 الظهر
أستحم، بعدها أدخل المطبخ مباشرة
ما أرتب أي شيء
مباشرةً على المطبخ
أسوي الأكل
المعجنّات والحلويات
وغيرها
بعد ما ننتهي من الفطور في المغرب
نبدأ بشغل البيت
ترتيب الغرف
والتنظيف والتكنيس والغسيل
كل شيء
هذا اللي يصير يوميًا
إلى
العيد
ولما يجي وقت الفطور
ونشرب المويه
الحمد لله
تحس الدنيا حلوة
ما أشهر الأكلات السعودية في رمضان؟
أول شيء
الحلويّات
ثاني شيء، المعجنات
ثالث شيء، المرق
الجريش، وغيرها
ما شاء الله
من الساعة 2
إلى وقت المغرب
السمبوسة
في بعض البيوت
إحنا اللي نسوّي العجينة نفسها
بس في بعض الأحيان
إحنا نشتريها من السوبر ماركت
السمبوسة، واللقيمات
إذا في حلويات لازم لقيمات
يوميًا لقيمات
يوميًا لازم لقيمات
ولازم السمبوسة
أكلة لا تحبين طبخها في رمضان؟
ورق العنب
ورق العنب لازم إحنا
نرتب الورق حقه. صح؟
يحتاج غسيل جيّد
بعدها تسوي الأرز
الأرز المصري
صح؟ الأرز المصري
مع اللحم المفروم وتقطيع البصل
ترتب هذا أوّل
بعدها تلف الورق
وتلفهم واحد واحد
ورق العنب مرّة صعب
وبعدها في الأخير
لازم تطبخ الباقي بعد
كيف شكل العلاقة المثالية بين العائلة والعاملة؟
لمّا يشترون ملابس من السوق
«ميمونة، هذا حقك أنتِ»
ما شاء الله مثل أهلي
مرّة مثل أهلي
لما مثلًا
«يلا ميمونة خلينا نروح السوبر ماركت»
يقولون أي شيء تبغينه خذيه
وهم الكفيل اللي يدفعون
يمكن عشان الراتب مو عالي
أكيد عشان كذا
أحيانًا إذا أنا
في المطبخ يساعدوني
أحيانًا يقولون
«ميمونة خلاص أنا اللي بسوّي القهوة»
«أنا اللي بسوّي الشاي»
أحيانًا كذا
لما رحت
كلهم كانوا
يبكون
كأني من أهلهم
جابوا لي كيكة
مثل حفلة يوم الميلاد
أصعب موقف مر عليك؟
لمّا كنت في المدينة
أبي توفى
لما توفى أبي
أنا كنت في المدينة
وسمعت خبر الوفاة
وقلت
«مدام أنا أبغى أرجع»
«أبغى أرجع لبلدي عشان أبي توفى»
لكنهم رفضوا
قالوا لازم أخلص العقد
ما تقدرين ترجعين
ولكن
أنا ما أقدر أسوي شيء
كان لازم أنهي مدة العقد
أنا ليه زعلت؟
مو من صاحبة المنزل
زعلت من كل شيء
ولكن مع الوقت
الحمدلله
رجعت قوية مرة ثانية
والبنات كانوا يطبخون
يقولون
«خلاص ميمونة. اليوم ما عندك شغل»
ولكن لسّا أصير زعلانة من هذا الشيء
بس مع الوقت، عدّت الحمد لله
مبسوطة؟
إيه بس حزنت شوي
لأني تذكرت الماضي مرة ثانيّة
هذا اللي أحزنني
ولكن كانت جميلة
أسوي كذا؟
صفّقي
شكرًا
عفوًا